second year show is different things to
different people but what it is mostly
is a show that's put on by the second
years and it's typically a satire of the
medical school the faculty the mission
of the school kind of those things that
drive you a little bit insane during the
course of your medical education started
in the in 1949 we think and it was
originally fourth years that put the
show on and as it progressed in the
1960s the second years took over
creating the show from the fourth years
and it continued on so in the 1950s Dean
leopard was actually going to ban the
show because of a couple of things that
happened in the show it was a little
risque but he didn't thankfully and the
tradition lives on today so staff
inception that's based on the movie
inception and the premise of the plot is
that Jim Jamison dr. Jim Jamison has
developed an inception device Danville
its key was the villain he decides that
he wants to incept the idea of shelf
exams into the medical student council
president chris sours mind and so the
show follows Chris as he goes through
the different dream layers so it starts
off with high school goes through
college medical school and finally ends
up in residency I think it says a lot
about the medical school I think it says
that we have great bonds without faculty
the fact that we're able to pick out
some of those things and rub them a
little bit and pocomoke some fun at them
and that they're okay with that and will
actually come to see that and support us
and donate to the show I think that says
a lot about the strength of the bond
between the faculty and the students
you